foreign [Music]
I'm Hodge tiger one of the group Partners at y
combinator today I'm going to talk about whether
you should start a startup because YC invests
in startups so early I've spent a lot of time
with people who aren't yet sure if they should
start a company or not I've helped many people
including my own friends and family think about
this decision at my intended audience for this
talk is anyone who doesn't feel ready to start
a startup today but thinks they may want to one
day in the future I'm going to break down the
topic of whether you should start a startup into
two parts first we'll talk about which types of
people seem best suited to being startup Founders
and help you figure out if you might be one of
them second we'll talk about how you might best
prepare yourself for becoming a startup founder
in the future let's start by helping you figure
out if you're the kind of person who should become
a startup founder or not I really wish there were
simple test you could take that would give you a
clear and correct answer to that question I've now
worked with almost a thousand startup Founders as
a group partner at YC and I still get surprised by
which people take to Startup life like a duck
to water and which ones struggle to adapt now
you might find this surprising if your image of
startups is based on the way famous Founders are
often depicted in books or movies these depictions
can make it seem that if you're not a ruthless
brilliant programmer like Mark Zuckerberg in The
Social Network movie or a charismatic product
genius like Steve Jobs in one of the many books or
movies about him you probably aren't cut out to be
a startup founder now I can't deny it that being
a brilliant programmer or a charismatic product
genius will certainly make it easier to be a
successful startup founder but I can say that
after working with many successful Founders
there are many more different types of people
who succeed as startups with different strengths
than just those stereotypes as an investor my job
is to pick which people will make great startup
Founders and yet even after 15 years of starting
and investing in startups I still get surprised
by who turns out to be a great startup founder
that means it's going to be hard for you to know
for sure if you're suited to being one you might
think you could just look at how well someone has
done in school or at work and assume success there
will lead to success of startups that's definitely
what I thought when I first started working at YC
in 2010 and began reading YC funding applications
for the first time after I started working with
more startups though I realized that these signals
mattered much less than I'd expected they would
when you're working on a startup you have to
put in Blood Sweat and Tears to convince even a
single user to care about trying your product let
alone convincing the first 10 or 100 you have to
push through a lot of rejection to get there and
because this is your startup all of that rejection
feels very personal in a way it doesn't when
you're working at a Fan Company building a product
for someone else it takes a lot of resilience
to make it through this initial struggle to get
your early users and that's the quality I think
is most important for startup Founders to have
resilient people are suited to startups and should
definitely become Founders but how do you know if
you have enough resilience to be a startup founder
when I first started working at yce I thought I
could use confidence as a proxy for resilience I'd
assume that if someone projected confidence like
speaking with conviction being high energy during
our funding interviews they were likely to be a
resilient founder the more Founders I worked with
though the more I realized this was also wrong
it turned out that someone could appear very
confident initially but not be resilient when
their startup hit roadblocks conversely some of
the quietest and least confident seeming Founders
at first turned out to be the most resilient
Founders I'd go on to work with many eventually
taking their companies public this is Saji the
founder of benchlink I met him when we funded
benjling in 2012. benjling is now worth over
six billion dollars and Sagi has grown into
a formidable founder and CEO but I remember when
we first interviewed him and his co-founder Corey
they were both softly spoken engineers and we
were all concerned they wouldn't be suited to
working on benchling because benchling's idea
was to sell software to biotech companies and
pharmaceutical companies to make money and we
weren't sure that they would be good at that
kind of Enterprise sales this concern was
shared by investors at demoday who worried
that they wouldn't be able to get those biotech or
pharmaceutical companies to pay for the benchling
software and benjling struggled to raise very
much seed funding at demoday sales did turn out
to be a real struggle for benchlink in fact over a
year after they'd graduated from YC benchling was
still not making any Revenue though they did
have some enthusiastic grad students as free
users and the product continued getting better
it took them almost another year that's now two
years after ycee to start doing sales and making
any Revenue now benchling is on calls to become
a public company someday and has many of the
world's top biotech and pharmaceutical companies
as customers looking back I always had confidence
that Sagi was a good engineer but I could not have
predicted back when we funded him in 2012 that he
would have the resilience to overcome that amount
of rejection and transform himself into the leader
of a company that took many years to become great
at Enterprise sales but what I haven't shared
with you are the stories of many other Founders
who seemed equally talented at first when we
first funded their companies but turned out
not to have the same amount of resilience as these
Founders did I've thought a lot about how to tell
the difference between people who have this kind
of startup resilience and those who don't I've
wondered if maybe having the right motivations or
reasons to start a company mean you're more likely
to have this special resilience over time though
I've decided that this also doesn't matter as much
as I had thought I think there are many perfectly
legitimate motivations to start a company for
example it's become popular to say that you
shouldn't start a company just to make money
that's considered a somewhat flimsy motivation but
I actually think it's fine to start a startup to
become rich startups are one of the few ways
to make life-changing amounts of money in a
relatively short period of time if the desire to
make money gets you started then great go for it
I also think that simply being curious about
what it's like to found a startup is a fine
initial motivation to start one actually doing
a startup is the only way to know for sure if
you'll enjoy it the reason I have conviction
that your initial motivations don't matter so
much is that I've seen motivation to change over
time I've seen Founders who started out a company
with a plan to sell it within a year change
their mind as they kept working the company
and they're still working on that same startup
a decade later and it's now a public company
this means that your initial motivations to
start a startup aren't as important as what
those motivations might change into over time in
order to keep working on a startup and keep going
through those dark periods that every startup
experience is you need enduring motivations
and I think the best ones are to be genuinely
interested in the problem you're working on and
love the people you're working with we'll talk
more about finding those later so instead of
introspecting too much on if you'll make a good
startup founder I'll offer some practical advice
if you are curious about what it'd be like to
start a company start by asking yourself what
do I have to lose now I mean this question not
as a rhetorical one but as a very practical one
figure out what the worst case scenario looks
like if you started a startup and decide if
you can live with that it's probably going to
take at least a year for you to have enough
data to tell if the startup you're working
on is promising enough to keep working on
in the worst case you'll shut down the company
without having earned much or any salary for
that year can you live without worst case
the calculus here is different for everyone
if you're about to graduate college taking a year
after graduating to work on a startup is not a big
deal those job offers will still be waiting for
you in a year but if you've been a Fang employee
for the past nine years and you're in line for a
big promotion this year then maybe you stand to
lose a lot by spending the next year working on a
startup instead asking yourself if you can handle
the worst case is the best way to know if you
should start a startup be honest with yourself if
you can't actually handle the worst case then your
own constant anxiety will probably self-sabotage
your startup efforts when you're thinking about
the worst case scenario of working on a startup
you should Factor something else into the equation
you will learn a lot from starting a company I
don't think enough people factor in how valuable
this learning is when they're doing their worst
case scenario analysis as a startup founder you're
responsible for making everything happen and that
means you get to do lots of different types
of work you'll have to do some amount of sales
product and customer support all at once this can
be very clarifying in helping you figure out what
type of work you enjoy and where you might want to
focus your career even if the startup doesn't work
out some people start a company that doesn't work
and then they jump straight back into starting
another one because they want to learn from their
mistakes others decide they actually really enjoy
specializing in doing one thing really well and
they join a company where they can do just that
the startup experience can really improve your
career opportunities even if the startup doesn't
succeed my second startup triple bite use software
to help companies identify and hire great people
I work with hundreds of employers as they search
for the best talent and I found that many of them
were explicitly looking to hire people who
had previous startup experience they believe
they showed evidence of being a self-starter and
being able to take initiative and Lead projects
some of the most successful YC companies have
actually built their hiring processes around this
knowledge Rippling a 10 billion dollar company
founded by Parker Conrad also a YC company hires
former Founders and puts them in charge of entire
product divisions usually we love hiring former
Founders to run specific product lines and and
build them and and really run them as general
managers we've been you know really successful at
recruiting I think we have Lao now probably around
50 former Founders that work at rip Lane at YC
we often see startup Founders leave this thought
up if it doesn't work out and go on to join a
more successful YC company this is Nick Grandy
YC funded his first startup wonderbar in 2008.
that startup shut down but he went on to join
another YC company you may have heard of Airbnb
as his first employee that of course worked out
great and after many years at Airbnb he left
to start another YC company out school which
is now valued at over 3 billion I share these
stories to show how career progressions are
not always perfectly linear introducing some
Serendipity and meeting smart ambitious people
can completely transform your career and being
a startup founder is a great way to do exactly
that okay so let's say you do decide you can
live with the worst case of doing a startup but
you're not ready to do one right now how can you
best prepare yourself to start one in the future
to actually start a company you'll want two things
an idea and a co-founder now sometimes an idea and
co-founder both come to you quickly and you're Off
to the Races there's lots of great startup content
out there about how to start a company once you're
ready but let's talk about what to do if it will
take you some time to get to that point I'd start
by encouraging you to not think of finding ideas
and co-founders as two separate tasks it's hard
to think up good ideas yourself also your ideas
will start out being vague and fuzzy more like
a hunch or an Impulse than a clearly formed idea
and you'll go through seven iterations of fleshing
it out into something more tangible and concrete
having someone to talk through that initial
idea or impulse with and debate and discuss
is important and the best person to do that with
is your co-founder I find my best ideas come to
me during conversations with smart people so I'd
start by thinking about who do you know that you
enjoy talking about ideas with in college these
are often the people you'll go to when you're
stuck on a hard problem or they are the people
you most enjoy working on group assignments with
at work these are the colleagues who you find
make you the most productive and help you do
your best work I'd see these people out and start
having conversations with them about ideas or
technologies that you find interesting talk about
products you use every day that you admire or are
frustrated by talk about Technologies
you think are underrated today and why
flesh your thoughts out and debate them spend
the time between these conversations doing your
own reading and research to learn more about the
topics you find interesting if you're a curious
person this will seem natural to you anyway all
of this primes your mind to more easily notice
and think of potential startup ideas and it helps
you get to know your friends or colleagues better
as potential co-founders if you're struggling to
think of people you enjoy talking about ideas with
then you probably need to change your environment
and meet some new people if you really want to
start a company one day it's best to choose an
environment where you will be around many people
who might someday be your co-founder I think the
best environment for this is working at a startup
you both get to see how a startup works from
the inside and your colleagues will be less
risk-averse than the average Fang employee so
if you're in college I'd recommend finding a
startup to work at after graduation or if you had
a fan company now think about leaving to join a
startup as an intermediate step to starting your
own someday once you're around smart people who
you enjoy talking about ideas with I'd recommend
you start experimenting with turning these ideas
into side projects at some point during these
conversations you'll eventually say something
like huh like it'd be cool if someone built X and
that's the moment to stop and think about how you
could be the one to build X is there a simple
first version you could build over a weekend or
can you find other people who might be users and
Pitch them on the idea to see how they react keep
pulling on this thread until you've come up with a
plan to turn this idea into something real however
small it is right now you're not trying to launch
the next unicorn you're just getting used to the
experience of turning ideas into reality and
experiencing the thrill of launching something
turn your idea into something real you'll
need the skills to actually build them
if you're not a programmer then either you need
to learn how to program or find a co-founder who
is a programmer my advice speaking from experience
is someone who started his first startup without
being able to code you start learning to code you
only need to learn enough to build a version one
of your ideas once you're around smart people
and you're working on some side projects
how do you know when it's time to take the leap
and quit your job to start a company while it'd
be great if one of your side projects started
getting explosive traction and made the decision
easy for you you can't rely on that happening if
you're serious about starting a company someday
even if you launch your side projects and get some
early users the feedback you get will be mixed
it's not uncommon for the early use of any product
to span the spectrum of being delighted appalled
and indifferent towards a product to judge how
promising your side project is as a startup idea
I'd use some advice from my y combinator partner
Paul bukhai he says that it is better to make a
product that a few people really love than one a
lot of people are indifferent Awards if your side
project elicits a deep reaction from someone the
kind where they can legitimately say that doing
something very differently as a result of your
product existing then you may be onto something a
single passionate user of a crude prototype that
was hacked together in a weekend means so much
more than a million sign-ups on a waitlist for
something that doesn't exist yet my main advice to
you would be to think less about how well your
side projects are going and think more about
how much you enjoying the process of thinking up
ideas and turning them into something real are you
learning new things and finding yourself energized
contrast this feeling with your day job if you
find your job is draining but you have energy
to work on your side projects on evenings and
weekends that's a sign it may be time to quit and
work on your own ideas pay particular attention to
how much you enjoy working with your side project
collaborators if you enjoy working with them and
you both want to be startup Founders recognize how
rare that is having a great co-founder who wants
to do a startup is a fantastic reason to quit and
start one to finish my advice is one don't worry
too much about your initial motivations or reasons
to start a company those can change over time
simply being curious about the experience
of starting a startup is enough to get going
think about the worst case scenario if you did
start a company and be sure you can live with that
if you don't yet have an idea or co-founder start
looking around for smart people to talk about
ideas with and launch some side projects
with actually launch those side projects
however small to get the experience of turning
ideas into reality and if you find someone you
really enjoy working with side projects with and
you both want to start a company make the jump
I really hope you do and I hope we get to work
together at YC Community someday thanks so much
[Music]